wie ist die lage heute am montagmorgen
vor ort ja morgen die lage ist natürlich
folgendermaßen der alltag ist zurück in
der stadt die menschen gehen zur arbeit
natürlich hier auf dieser einkaufsstraße
bleiben natürlich viele noch stehen
gucken sich die beschädigungen an die in
dieser nacht entstanden sind da und man
muss natürlich auch sagen es ist nach
wie vor das gesprächsthema ob egal ob in
der u-bahn oder beim bäcker die menschen
unterhalten sich natürlich immer noch
über das was in dieser nacht passiert
ist was bedeutet denn die verwüstungen
der einzelnen läden für deren besitzer
und auch für die kommende öffnung
hoffentlich bald wieder
ja also wir können das jetzt hier sehen
an diesem ein euro job den er ist ja
auch teil der videos die in den sozialen
netzwerken kursieren ja oder der kollege
kann auch hier einmal über schwenken das
sieht man das kaufhaus in dass der mob
versucht hat einzudringen da sind die
allerdings an dieser massiven verglasung
bescheid hat hier haben wir vorhin auf
sind darauf einen glaser getroffen er
hat uns erzählt wenn die türen
beschädigt sind dann ist das nicht etwas
was man von einem tag auf den anderen
wieder in ordnung bringen kann sondern
das dauert wahrscheinlich so zwei drei
wochen bis dahin können die
geschäftsinhaber ihre läden notdürftig
öffnen das heißt die türen sind den
ganzen tag geöffnet und wenn feierabend
ist dann kommen da wieder die bretter
braucht dann muss zugenagelt werden also
nach dem corona locker und jetzt auch
noch das für die stuttgarter
ladenbesitzer weiß man denn schon was
neues über die täter konnte man dann
bisher alle täter ausfindig machen was
passiert mit den jetzt also bislang sind
24 täter in der nacht noch festgenommen
worden sieben davon sollen heute dem
haftrichter vorgeführt werden und da ist
die polizei wahrscheinlich auch setzen
ver sichtlich dass es zu einem abkommen
wird was jetzt mit den anderen rund 470
litern was mit denen passieren soll ist
natürlich klar der polizeipräsident hat
es ja auch gerade ebenfalls angesprochen
er sagte man soll sich darauf verlassen
dass alle täter ermittelt werden und
jetzt beginnt natürlich einen sitz
arbeit also die polizei wird mit akribie
natürlich videos sichten und versuchen
alle täter habhaft zu werden dabei
kommen auch beamte zum einsatz und
speziell geschult sind täter aus
menschenmengen heraus wieder zu
identifizieren